from hiding secrets in the background to
straight up stealing characters from
other shows these are 26 things you
surely missed in my hero Academia in
chapter 1 while the story explains the
origin of quirks a very interesting
panel is shown featuring many shadowy
figures however if you take a closer
look you may notice that some of them
seem oddly familiar that's because they
are some of the most popular fictional
heroes in the world like Spider-Man
Ultraman Kamen Rider Moonlight mask and
even Superman although he never got to
actually see these heroes in the show
many of my hero academia's characters
seem to be based on them all might is a
combination of Superman and Captain
America izawa shares similarities to
Batman and Cerro from class 1a is a
clear reference to Spider-Man while we
are talking about superheroes there is a
character in the series that is a
complete reference to Deadpool do you
know which one it is if you guess twice
you are right not only is their
appearance really similar but they both
also act in a similar manner however
popular superhero references aren't the
only thing hidden in my hero Academia
the other animes are as well for example
during the provisional license exam
Todoroki fights a group of ninjas that
seem really similar to the shinobis from
Naruto they even have the same headbands
this is because the author of Naruto
Musashi Kishimoto is actually a good
friend of my hero academia's author and
they've done an official crossover
together Kishimoto even made a sketch of
Naruto cheering Deku which symbolizes
passing the torch from one anime to
another besides other animes and
superhero references in Chapter 3 of my
hero Academia there is actually a
reference to one of the most popular
characters in video game history while
President Mike is explaining exam rules
to the students we can see this
illustration do these Silhouettes seem
familiar to you well they should as this
is clearly a reference to Super Mario
the other Silhouettes are all enemies
from the Super Mario Universe like
Goombas Koopa troopas and the piranha
plant this great detail was
unfortunately removed in the anime
version and replaced with robots Okay
you may already know some of the secrets
so far but this was only the first stage
and it'll only get crazier from here
let's now talk about some secrets that
anime only is 100 missed during the The
Joint training Arc bakugou changes into
his winter gear and Deku is quick to
complement his new looks however bakugou
being bakugou gets so mad at Deku that
he even starts biting his text bubble
another funny interaction between Deku
and bakugo that never made it into the
anime happened in chapter 167 while in
the math class Deku is trying so hard to
solve the math problem and when he
finally says his answer you can see
bakugou in the corner being annoyed
however when it turns out that his
answer is incorrect you can see bakugou
smirking and my hero Academia Secrets
Don't stop there as in the film two
Heroes a really familiar movie character
appears that character is Pro Hero
Godzilla which obviously represents the
king of monsters Godzilla this cool
little detail was possible because the
company that produced the movie also
holds the rights to the Godzilla
franchise but that's not even the
coolest movie reference you see kohe
hirikoshi my hero academia's author is a
huge Star Wars fan and he left so many
cool Star Wars Secrets throughout the
show for example remember that beach
that Deku cleared while training with
all might it's called daguba Municipal
beach park an obvious reference to the
planet Dagobah there is also this mall
called Wookies which is a reference to
the place kashyyk where the wookies from
Star Wars come from however by far the
coolest Star Wars reference was right in
front of our noses the whole time this
is all for one the main antagonist of my
hero Academia does these design seem
familiar to you even I didn't realize
when I first watched the show but this
guy is basically the same as Darth Vader
just think about it they are both
leaders of evil organizations refused to
reveal their true identities and wear
similar machine helmets to help them
breathe wow I can't believe I didn't
notice this sooner and we can't make an
Easter egg video without mentioning at
least one JoJo reference thankfully my
hero Academia has a perfect one in
season 2 episode 21 while kirishima and
Sato are participating in an exam
against cementos a wall suddenly appears
in front of them and what do they do
well let's just say they break it in a
very familiar style toga a very cheerful
and sadistic member of the league of
villains is often shown wearing a face
mask that helps her avoid inhaling toxic
gas but this doesn't seem like your
usual gas mask how did horikoshi even
come up with a design like this well it
turns out toga's mask is the exact same
mask Bane wears in the Batman movie The
Dark Knight Rises some of these secrets
were pretty cool but let's take it a
step further and cover some secrets that
I am sure 90 of you missed we already
talked about how twice is based on
Deadpool but what if I tell you that an
actual Deadpool appears in season 4
episode 24 while the new Hero rankings
are presented if you pause right at 16
minutes and 20 seconds you can catch a
glimpse of Deadpool in the audience
another thing that the show tried super
hard to hide is this cool secret in
Chapter 259 while heroes are teaming up
to attack the Paranormal Liberation
Front you can see a bunch of cool
looking heroes in the crowd but if you
look all the way to the left you'll
notice a familiar face it's actually
denji from chainsaw man looks like even
he wants to stop shigaraki there is also
a character in class 1B called herota
shishida and his entire design is a
clear reference to beasts from the X-Men
franchise just look at their pictures
next to each other besides both being
human beasts they also wear glasses and
have protruding lower teeth and if
that's not enough to convince you
herota's Quirk is literally called Beast
come on you can't get any more obvious
than that but I bet you have no idea
what UA stands for in the name of Deku
School you've heard the name of this
school literally hundreds of times
throughout the series but did you ever
stop to wonder what these two mysterious
letters actually mean well you see in
Japanese the word hero is pronounced a
you and when you invert it you get UA so
the letters actually don't mean anything
in English it's just a Japanese pun for
the word hero in my hero Academia Movie
World Heroes Mission there is a scene
where Deku is accused of being a mass
murderer on live TV at first you may not
notice anything unusual with this scene
but if you take a closer look at the TV
station's logo you'll notice that it's
almost identical to the Fox TV logo from
the real world blue background white
lines and even this red part at the
bottom they didn't even try to hide it
in episode 27 while Deku and Gran Torino
are unboxing the new microwave that just
arrived if you pause just at the right
moment you can see a really cool Amazon
reference on the box or I better say
almost on did you know that most of my
hero academia's names actually have
meaning behind them take bakugo's name
for example if we split it into two
parts we'll get Baku and go these words
literally mean bomb and Power in
Japanese another great example is denki
whose full name means electric and
thunder okay if you knew all of these so
far you are a true mha fan but there is
still one stage of Secrets left that I
am sure
99.9 of you missed did you ever wonder
how did horikoshi come up with Momo's
costume well I did and after a lot of
research I actually found where it's
from the pretty much same costume is
worn by DC Comics villain Victoria
Wanderer you literally can't deny
similarities here in episode 87 while
Endeavor and Hawks are walking through
the city there is this one Endeavor fan
who is too afraid to ask for an
autograph he only appears briefly but if
you pause right here and think about it
you'll notice that this guy looks
exactly exactly same as the main
character from Fair field Natsu this
is even better when is that he is also
also by Natsu's voice actor in episode
49 if you pass exactly at 14 minutes and
5 Seconds you can see another character
who definitely doesn't belong in this
anime this time it's Scar from Full
Metal Alchemist All Pro heroes in My
Hero Academia have their hero names and
while some are cool the others are just
straight up ridiculous however one name
that may be a bit confusing is ita's
hero name ingenium what does it even
mean well after some research I found
out what it means and it all makes sense
now ingenium is the name for the
automobile engine family and since eda's
Quirk is literally called engine it's a
perfect name for him but to the way all
might and Deku perform this attack seem
familiar for some reason if it did it's
probably because it's really similar to
how Gohan and Goku performed their
combined attack in Dragon Ball there are
also other Dragon Ball references in the
series check this guy out he literally
wears cyan armor another great detail is
in my hero academia's spin-off manga
Vigilantes here the main character can
be seen practicing his Quirk and yeah
you can probably see where I'm going
with this there is another Cool Secret
in the movie two Heroes throughout this
movie there are a lot of Easter eggs but
one that caught my attention is
definitely the one involving these two
their names are David and Melissa and
their last name is Shield ring any bells
knowing hirikoshi's love for Western
Comics this is obviously a reference to
the organization's shield from Marvel
Comics click on this video where we
explained all deku's forms in my hero
Academia